if your water breaks that means the baby
is coming very soon if only eating the
placenta is good for you
no
don't go there labor usually lasts a
couple of hours perhaps the biggest myth
that we will talk about today hi i'm dr
laura riley and i'm a high risk
obstetrician at new york presbyterian
hospital while cornell medicine my
favorite thing to do is delivering
babies and i'm dr dina goffman i'm also
a high-risk pregnancy physician i'm the
chief of ob at new york presbyterian
columbia university irving medical
center and today we will be debunking
myths about childbirth oh this is good
wide hips mean easier birth this is a
total myth and what we see as your hips
aren't even reflective of like what's
going on with the bones in your pelvis
which do matter the bony pelvis is
connected by cartilage which is softer
which loosens up in the course of the
latter part of pregnancy so that gives
the baby a little bit more room and then
labor all those contractions and the
coordination
that forces the head into the pelvis a
lot of that depends on the baby right i
think one thing that is frustrating for
people is they will say at 38 weeks am i
gonna have a vaginal delivery we can't
tell
because there's so many other factors
that go into
whether or not your baby is coming out
vaginally it's not just the baby's size
it's the baby's position
it's how well the baby tolerates holding
its breath every three minutes there's
more to the story the best position to
labor and give birth on is your back
that's a myth what you might see on
television or in the movies of a patient
flat on their back is actually the worst
position to labor and give birth in we
love to have patients be in bed
certainly on their side but there's also
a lot of opportunity to be sitting up
and even to be walking around depending
again on the situation with your
pregnancy your baby and your labor
there's the opportunity potentially to
take a shower some people use birthing
balls as a place to sit many places now
have wireless fetal monitoring where you
actually can even monitor the baby while
you're moving around and a lot also
depends on whether or not you have
anesthesia because once you have an
epidural it is fabulous for taking away
the discomfort on your abdomen and those
contractions but it does in many ways
weaken
your leg muscles
so most
hospitals will not allow you to walk
around with your epidural in just
because you may not be as strong this is
definitely a myth you can induce labor
by eating spicy food so this is a myth
there are a number of them out there all
of the things that people think you can
do to induce labor pineapples cream
cheese bumpy roads sex
sex that one
there's some truth to it right nipple
stimulation that's not a myth i know
it's not nipple stimulation actually
does work the tough part about nipple
stimulation is that you get so many
contractions at once your baby doesn't
love it the sex and the nipple
stimulation
have sort of valid plausible reasons why
they may help but i think there's not
sort of a protocol for how to do it and
how to do it safely we know how to
induce labor we have different
medications that we can use
vaginally medications that we can use in
the iv and we know how to do that safely
i think there is no evidence for spicy
foods sex is fine if it's comfortable
and something that you want to be doing
walking being active kind of getting out
and about but i think this baby's gonna
come when the baby's gonna come your
water breaks with no warning i know
people see it in the tv and movies and
it's a very dramatic event and it's
clear-cut and you rush to the hospital
the baby is born that's not always how
it happens sometimes it does break with
a huge gush and it's very obvious
sometimes there's a leak and patients
are unsure and sometimes people don't
know whether it's urine or it's their
water breaking if it's urine it comes
out and then it stops
and if it's your water
it continues it does not stop so put a
pad on
and if the pad is
consistently wet and saturated you have
to think gee maybe my water broke
sometimes we will break your water for
you for some patients they will be in
labor and progressing nicely in labor
and the water will not have broken on
its own if you're unsure whether or not
your water is broken it's better to come
in and let us tell you yes or no rather
than stay at home because if your water
has broken and there's a long time
before your delivery you do increase the
risk for getting an infection if your
water breaks that means the baby is
coming very soon if only yeah we wish
this is not always the case it is all
over the map because a lot depends on
how many children you've had if it's
your fourth baby and you're contracting
in your water breaks it's coming fast if
it's your first baby your water breaks
you're not contracting it could be 12 24
hours so it's hard to know contractions
that come consistently with the baby's
head against the cervix are what makes
the cervix open the cervix has to get to
10 centimeters before you can push so
that process
is the process of labor
if your water breaks in the course of
that process great but that doesn't tell
us the timing for some subset of our
patients the water will break and the
patient may not be in labor that happens
in probably eight to ten percent of
patients so if you think your water is
broken
you should call your provider and say my
water's broken i am contracting or not
contracting and when should i come in
because that answer is going to vary
depending on the circumstances around
your pregnancy eating the placenta is
good for you
no
don't go there absolutely not please
please don't eat your placenta many
patients will ask about the utility of
eating the placenta there was some
suggestion that eating the placenta
after birth
might prevent depression anxiety and
while we're completely supportive of
doing anything to prevent those issues
i think we have to recognize that
there's no science behind the placenta
being helpful to that there was actually
a recent publication from the american
academy of pediatrics that outlined some
of these less traditional practices
surrounding birth and this one is
specifically mentioned and that paper
calls out the infectious risk without
added benefit so we're happy to have
these conversations to talk with
patients through shared decision-making
processes but our recommendation will
almost always be
you should not eat the placenta instead
of eating the placenta it's really
important to pay attention to your
nutrition your hydration
your rest when you can with a newborn
and lots of support from family and
friends labor usually lasts a couple of
hours there are occasionally patients
who've had children in the past who
start to contract at home and come in
and quickly have a birth with us but it
is definitely the exception not the rule
depends on how many kids you've had
labor usually last i'd say 12 to 24
hours is average for your first baby
second third
way faster thank goodness the labor
process has multiple stages and phases
the early part of labor can take a fair
amount of time some people will start
with cramping then the cramping is like
unbearable and then they'll realize it's
contractions those contractions then
are maybe 20 minutes apart and then
they're 10 minutes apart and you
actually need a lot of contractions that
are three minutes apart consistently
to soften the cervix and most people
will do some of that at home for several
hours
and then they'll call us and say i think
i'm in labor and then we'll say
come on in once you get to sort of that
six
or so
centimeters things start to speed up and
then you eventually get to you know
10 centimeters and then the real work
happens usually you will begin to push
shortly after you are determined to be
10 centimeters and then that pushing
process is called the second stage of
labor and it's from the time that you're
fully dilated until the time that your
baby is out once the cord is clamped and
cut then we go on to the next step which
is we need to deliver the placenta we
then are going to do some things to help
prevent you from bleeding so that's sort
of the last piece making sure that we
identify and repair tears that were
created during the birth process doctors
slapped the baby on the back after birth
that's a myth
that's old school
and the movies i think actually i was
just gonna say i think actually it's the
movies i think that it comes from the
desire to
stimulate the baby to take a big deep
breath after we clamp the cord but you
don't really have to do that the babies
do it on their own they start crying so
sometimes you will see us rub the baby's
back or tap the bottom of the baby's
feet just to sort of make it go up
and then it takes deep breath coughs up
fluid and then starts screaming an
epidural increases the chance of needing
a c-section myth epidural does not
increase the risk of needing a c-section
i think that misinformation comes from
the fact that some patients
probably get the epidural so early that
they're not even in labor and then it
becomes intervention after intervention
after intervention
and some people end up with a c-section
they'll explain the risks they'll
explain the benefits and they'll explain
the alternatives which is always to not
have one but the risks that they will
talk about are a tiny risk of infection
and a very small risk of a headache
after the procedure again this is shared
decision making at its best it's great
to have options for what you're going to
use to manage labor because labor is
painful get the epidural early before
it's too late that's a myth yeah this is
a myth but it's a really common one that
we hear we wouldn't want you to get an
epidural if you're not in labor there
really is no too late unless it's that
the baby's coming
or that you're unable to really sit
still for them to place the epidural
itself i think it's our job to sort of
work with you to figure out when is that
just right for you and it may not be the
same for every patient if you show up
and you're 10 centimeters and you're
like i want an epidural i will actually
talk you down from that ledge because
it's not that you can't get the epidural
it takes about 15 minutes to get the
effect of the epidural so
15 minutes into your 10 centimeters and
pushing your baby might be out by then
have the conversation with the
anesthesia team even if you're not ready
to commit meet the people
learn about the risks and benefits
before you're in
the active phase of labor incredibly
uncomfortable when it becomes harder to
listen and process information
c-sections are the easy way out myth
myth you don't want a c-section unless
you need to have a c-section if you
compare
maternal risks associated with a vaginal
delivery
to a c-section
essentially
everything is a little bit higher with a
c-section and what do i mean by
everything you have a greater risk of
infection a greater risk of bleeding and
a greater risk of having a blood clot
after the delivery and the recovery is
definitely longer the surgery itself is
complicated so we in general don't want
you to have surgery unless there's a
reason you need to cut the cord as soon
as the baby's out so this is a myth
we've really moved towards something
called delayed cord clamping which means
we deliver the baby we place the baby on
the patient's abdomen or chest the cord
is still connected from the baby's belly
button to the placenta that's still in
the uterus and there's still blood flow
going through that cord and there have
been studies showing that there are
benefits to not clamping and cutting
immediately if you don't have to we keep
an eye on the clock we keep an eye on
mom and baby and then when the timing is
appropriate we'll clamp the cord and
either cut it but typically ask you or
your support person or whoever else is
participating in the birth if they'd
like to participate by cutting the cord
it's harder than it looks and i do say
that often to the support person when i
hand them the scissors sometimes it
takes more than one snip with the
scissor to sort of get through that cord
it doesn't hurt the baby that's another
question i get all the time doing yoga
poses can turn your breech baby have you
seen any studies i haven't seen good
evidence that it's true if you're asking
us is there scientific research to say
that downward dog or the flashlight or
the voices helps
i think the answer would be no
i think if you ask us
do any of these things hurt
i also think the answer is no
as long as you can safely do a downward
dog and yoga i definitely find patients
worried about it when they have an
ultrasound at 28 weeks that the baby is
breached and they think the answer to
that is that's totally normal when
you're approaching 37 weeks and then is
when we have to start having a
conversation
about how do we want to handle this
breach that's true but there are plenty
of times where the baby is breach at 37
weeks you schedule a c-section for 39
weeks and you come in on the day of your
c-section and the baby's head down so it
happens kids are still moving and still
quite active even after 37 weeks
knowledge is power thinking about the
labor process and the birth process
talking to your provider getting a sense
of the practice the unit what things are
like there are actually really really
important to help lead to a really
smooth positive birth experience i think
that this is where the birth plan is
helpful having some knowledge and
knowing what you can expect i think just
gives you a much better
birth experience